معنا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده اللواء اختبار
هذا الصاروخ البالستي الذي يصل المداه الى
الف كيلو متر اما اهميته
يعني اولا لم نفاجئ لماذا لان لم يبدا
العمل من الصفر تفكك الاتعادي السوفيتي
افضى الى سيطره كل دوله على ما يوجد على
اراضيها وبالتالي ورثه اوكرانيا
30% من القاعده الصناعيه العسكريه و40% من
قاعده البحث العلمي وبالتالي استونى هذا
الصاروخ الجديد امر طبيعه ان يتم تحقيق
هذا الانجاز وبالتالي هذا يعوق الجانب
الاوكراني عن التحفظات الغربيه الامريكيه
تحديدا بعدم استهداف العنق الروسي الان
اوكرانيا وهناك اشارات من الغرب ومتعددين
رسميين في امريكا بان السلاح الذي هو
بالاصل تصنيع اوكراني اوكرانيا هي صاحبه
القرار في اتخاذها او عدم اتخاذه استخدامه
رغم عدم الرغبه في ذلك التوجه لكنها لا
تستطيع ان تمنعها من استخدام التاريخ كما
في حال صواريخ نبتون التي دمرت
موسكافا
ان تفرض على الجانب الاوكراني عدم
الاستخدام تمنعها باستخدامه مارس وبالتالي
هذا يعني توسيع دائره القتال الى ما يصل
الى الف كيلو متر وهذا يعيدنا الى استهداف
قاعده انجلز الرئيس الاوكراني لواء فايزه
الدويري تحدث عن وصول هذه الصواريخ قيد
الاختبار الى داخل دنياتك بالمدى الذي
تتحدث عنه حول قدره هذه الصواريخ ما حقيقه
امكانياتها وما الذي ستغيره في واقع هذه
الحرب
يعني هي الان التاثير يعتمد على مجموعه من
العوامل الان المواصفات الفنيه للصاروخ
زينه الراس الحربي غير معروفه المعروف
الان المدى وبالتالي اذا
الارتباط التاثير الفعلي بالمدى
ووزن الحموله او الراس المتفجر لا نملك
معلومات عن وزن الراس المتفجر ولكن يفترض
انه يحمل العشرات من الكيلو جرامات من
المتفجرات في الحد الادنى هذا هذا الامر
يعني اصابه اي قاعده عسكريه وقاصه قواعد
سلاح الجو سيكون له نتائج مؤلمه على
الجانب الروسي استهداف جسر كيرش من مسافه
700 كيلو متر او الف كيلو متر هذا امر
يلقي بضلاله على مجريات المعركه اذا هو
الان نحن امام ثالوث طبيعه الهدف المدى
زينه الراس المتفجر
اذا ما تم توظيف هذا الثالوث بصوره جيده
ستكون الانعكاسات ايجابيه لصالح الجانب
الاوكراني حسنا ما الذي يحاول كل جانب ان
يفعله والان الروسي يتحدثون عن التصدي لكل
الهجمات الاوكرانيه خاصه بالمسيرات
وانه في ذات الوقت يحاولون اختراق يعني
احداث اي اختراق على الجانب الروسي
يعني الان الجانب الاوكراني الورقه
الرابحه بيده اصبحت الطائرات المسيره
والزوارق الحربيه
المسيره لماذا لانها ان لم تنجح في الوصول
فهي
ترسل رساله اخرى عمليه الارباح لاحظ الان
جسر كيرش هذا الشريان الحيوي لنقل المعدات
العسكريه
ودلالاته الرمزيه فيما يتعلق بالرئيس
بوتين لاحظ بالنسبه الان منطقه
الموسكو الوصول الى اطراف موسكو قد يكون
التاثير المادي قليل جدا ولكن مجرد
اكتشاف طائر المسيره باتجاه موسكو تتوقف
الحركه الجويه في اربعه مطارات اذا حتى في
حال الفشل
تقدم بعض الايجابيات الجانب الاوكراني رغم
الحديث عن احداث تقدمات فيزا باولوجيا في
اوريث وغيرها لا يزال الحديث متواضع عن
متواضع جدا وبالتالي ما هي الورقه البديله
بايد الجانب الاوكراني هي استخدام الوسائل
الاخرى منها الان الطائرات المسيره واذا
تم ترجمه تصريحات الجانب الاوكراني عن
الصواريخ سيكون هناك مسار اخر من عمان
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي شكرا جزي